[Music]
my name is Jonathan and I work on the
mobile ninjas we're a team within Google
passionate about testing and testability
if you've ever written test for Android
before it's likely you've used some of
our products espresso Robo electric or
the Android testing support library and
together these tools combine for
billions of testing vocations both
within and outside of Google so today
there's a general consensus within the
software development community are the
virtues of writing tests sure there's a
cost to writing tests but it's accepted
one and is one that quickly pays
dividends throughout the lifecycle of
your project tests provide fast feedback
on failures like a bug caught early on
in development is far cheaper to fix
than after you've deployed your
application they give you a safety net
for making changes to your code you're
free to refactor cleanup and optimize
safe in the knowledge that you're not
going to break any of the existing
functionality and what's more a suite of
readable tests provides the living
breathing specification of your
applications behavior now in software
development there exists the concept of
the testing pyramid it's made up of
three layers unit integration and
end-to-end tests and as you go up the
pyramid you're gaining fidelity but this
comes at the expense of test execution
time it also gets harder to maintain and
debug these kinds of tests but just like
a rock band where you need a perfect
blend of musicians to create that great
track each layer in the pyramid is
equally important you're leveraging the
Vantage's of one layer to compensate for
trade-offs in others to produce a
holistic automated testing environment
we recommend a 70-20-10 split as a
general healthy guideline
and now while the rules of these
pyramids still apply some of the unique
characteristics of Android development
have introduced some difficulties along
the way so unit tests due to their need
to be fast will run on the local
workstation an integration and
end-to-end tests due to their need to
run in a really faithful environment
tend to run on a rail or a virtual
device and so separate tools are evolved
at each layer of the pyramid robolectric
or the mockable android framework for
your off device unit tests espresso and
the Android testing support library for
those on device tests now androids got
some really familiar core concepts such
as getting a handle to your application
context or maybe driving your activity
lifecycle and each of these tools has
its own distinct api's and ways of doing
things
for achieving these exact same tasks now
this has led to something of a test
writing crisis as a developer it's hard
sometimes to know what tools are
available for use and which of those are
recommended having multiple tools at
each level has led to an explosion of
styles each with their own distinct
patterns and api's and this in turn
leads to a lack of mobility between
layers tests can't easily be refracted
or reused between layers in a pyramid
without being completely rewritten for a
new tour to discuss this further let's
orientate ourselves with what
constitutes a well-structured test so
there's some following common patterns
that define a well-structured test and
so we generally break tests down into
three clear sections given when and then
and I like to separate them with a blank
line to clearly demarcate them so given
some predetermined state of the system
when you execute an action that you wish
to test then verify the new state of the
system or some behavior has occurred
be sure to name the test after both the
condition you're testing and the
expected outcome keep the test focused
on very specific behavior and then test
all your behaviors independently unless
it's always more with tests these
guidelines will help you keep each test
understandable in isolation use common
setup methods only for scaffolding this
is maybe creating the object that's
under test and wiring up some of its
dependences let's take a look at the
problem of the explosion of styles and
we'll highlight this using a simple test
case we'll have a single activity with
one button that responds to a click
sending an intent to the Android system
and I'm going to walk you through at
this test case comparing the different
styles of mockito
Robo electric or espresso so first up
let's consider mojito now mocking is a
really powerful tool but is one that's
often overused and sometimes used
inappropriately mocking your own classes
is great but while mocking the android
framework may seem like a great idea at
first it consumed lead down a path of
difficult problems many Android classes
are stateful or they have complex
contracts and these are really difficult
or even impossible to satisfy with marks
so even though we don't recommend it
let's just start by taking a look at one
of these tests and walk through it using
the mojito framework to mock the android
framework so in the given section we can
you a power activity under tests but
look we first of all have to stub out
some of the android framework behavior
in the superclass activity so that it
responds as we expect in our tests
now this introduces some problems first
of all were partially stubbing the class
under test and this means we're not
testing the true behavior of that object
on the test and furthermore it brings
with it excessive stubbing which
introduces all this undesirable
boilerplate and that quickly becomes
distracting from the true intention of
your test for the when section of the
test to execute your code under test
you'd have first had to need to register
an argument captor earlier to get a
handle on that click listener which you
will then vote manually to to call the
code that you're wishing to test now
with this approach you can soon descend
into a undesirable mess of argument
captors stubbing calls and answer
invocations finally in the then section
to obtain ten intent sent to the Android
system you can have to use another
argument captor in mocking the Android
frameworks in this way tends to force
you into a testing implementation
details when you want to be testing
behavior instead and furthermore these
drawbacks have tended to lead to
developers to build their own
abstractions to isolate Android this
little turn leads to its own set of
problems firstly you're introducing
another layer of Krofft into your
application and secondly you're
introducing text in gaps where bugs can
hide and we believe that while you
should architect your application very
thoughtfully the limitations of the
tools shouldn't dictate your application
architecture either so let's see how
this looks like with robolectric
robolectric is the popular open source
testing framework it allows you to
follow the best practices surrounding
marks as you're able to use real Android
objects in your tests rather than having
to program your own stubbing behavior in
each test it runs on your local host
which means it's very fast making it
ideal for unit tests robolectric tends
to create tests that
a lot cleaner so let's walk through each
section in turn in the given section we
can simply bring an activity into the
resume state for our test just by
calling robe electrics setup activity
API in the when section we're able to
use real Android SDK api's such as fine
view by ID to get ahold of the view and
then robolectric s-- click on api safely
click on that view and invoke the code
that we wish to test and finally in the
vent section we again use robe electrics
own testing api's to check that the
intent was sent to the system see how
much cleaner this version is we're
focusing on the items that really matter
in the test and were free of all those
extra pieces of distraction now espresso
is a UI testing framework and it runs on
a real or a virtual device it provides
you with a really realistic environment
the trade-off here is a much slower
execution speed you're building up your
entire apk deploying it to the device
and instantiating the test run waiting
for the results and then collecting
those back on your local workstation all
of this is adding valuable development
cycles now the exact same android
concepts exist here we're just getting
hold of an activity clicking a button
and then verifying an intent was sent
the Android system here though as you'll
see the api's are very different let's
step through this one together so in the
given section we'll use the activity
test role which comes from the Android
testing support library this can be used
to start an activity bring it to the
resume state and provide us with a
handle to it in our tests
for the when section we can use the
espresso view matcher api's they'll find
the view in question and then safely
click on it to invoke the code that we
wish to test and finally in the vent
section we use the espresso intents
library to capture that tent and verify
that it was the one that we wanted sent
to the system notice here but a Twila
test has many similar structures to
robolectric test the example that we saw
earlier the syntax is very very
different so while each of these testing
frameworks have contrasting strengths
and weaknesses it's this explosion of
styles that's really become the big
problem for writing tests who in the
audience has been using robolectric to
write tests
raise your hands and what about espresso
and who's using both we often hear
developers talking about I need to write
a robolectric test or I need an espresso
test but we'd much rather you be
thinking about writing an Android test
instead we feel as a developer that no
matter what kind of test you're writing
you shouldn't first have to think about
environments and tools and libraries
that you'll need we believe that you
shouldn't have to suffer the mental load
of having to learn multiple sets of
api's for doing exactly the same thing
so and of course you should have the
freedom to refactor and reuse your code
no matter where you choose to run it so
what if there was only one set of API is
that you needed to learn and now imagine
also being freedom to focus on writing
your tests rather than considering those
tools and libraries and environments
well to make this a reality today we're
launching android test it's part of
jetpack with jetpack testing is now a
first-class citizen of the Android tool
chain will unifying the development
experience around a canonical high
quality set of api's that will reduce
the boilerplate and eliminate the number
of tools that you need to learn
naturally Kotlin in support is included
allowing you to write beautifully
concise tests and of course all of this
will be open sourced
we love contributions from our community
members we're going to satisfy
developers needs in each of the four key
sections of a test
remember scaffolding given when and then
scaffolding encompasses the
configuration and control api's think
getting a hold of that application
context for your test scaffolding
Android j-unit foreigners used to
execute your tests you can use the
instrumentation registry to get a handle
to that application context well today
we're excited to announce for the very
first time you can now use these api's
for both your on and off device tests
the next section of a test is the given
section and here we're going to provide
two key categories of api's for you
firstly the under Jamiat rules from the
Android testing support library will
become part of jetpack and will soon
adding more api's to help drive the
component life cycles for you in tests
as you've seen previously the activity
tests for all is used to start up your
activity and make it available to your
tests in the resume state you probably
use this API running on a device many
times before well today this API too
will be available for tests that run off
device as well secondly we'll be
providing you with a set of Android test
data builders these will help you
construct Android objects that your code
on the test will interact with
many of the android framework classes
that you need to have for setting up
your test date are difficult to create
often there's no public constructor so
they can't be instantiated for tests
perhaps their final so mocking is out of
the question either and sometimes they
just plain clumsy to instantiate with
any degree of brevity at all so we're
including Android test builders within
jetpack to give you a concise way to set
up your test environment they produce
readable code they're fluent way to
create the Android components that you
need to interact with and of course
they're portable Android test data
builders work for both your on and off
device use cases the third section of a
well-structured test is the when section
exercising the code under tests usually
this is just simply a case of calling
your own code directly but when you're
writing a UI test it's likely that you'd
write for the reach for the espresso
view match your api's today we're happy
to announce that espresso 2 is joining
Android test jetpack espresso view API
is a fluent and they read beautifully
you've used them for you're off on
device tests for a while now and today
we're providing preliminary support for
these tests in the off device use case
also the final part of a well structured
test is a Ven section this is where you
make assertions on the state of the
system in response to an action so
firstly espresso intense two is going to
be joining jetpack as Android test
intense those intense ap is that you've
been using for your on device testing
great news today they too will run in
your off device tests and finally we're
also releasing an assertions library to
help reduce the boilerplate in your
tests
using traditional Jay Manette assertions
can lead to tests that are not
immediately readable see here how easy
it is to get the actual in the expected
arguments mixed up an Android uses a lot
of integer constants for efficiency but
this makes it difficult to comprehend
the error messages in tests at Google we
love to use truth it's our own open
source fluent testing assertions library
using a fluent assertions library is a
great step to producing more readable
code and writing the tests become much
more easy too because you can lean on
the built-in support of your ideas Auto
completion feature so to help you write
concise tests against Android code we'll
be releasing a set of truth extensions
for Android which reduces the
boilerplate read beautifully and gives
immediately meaningful error messages of
course these assertions will work across
all environments both neon and off
device tests so with jetpack Android
tests we'll be bringing you the tools
that you need so that you can
concentrate on writing beautifully
concise easy to read tests without first
worrying about libraries or tools or
environments a single set of canonical
api's for common tasks that will reduce
the boilerplate leaving your test clear
and readable and a very environmentally
agnostic allowing you to run the test
either on device on your local
workstation or perhaps in a cloud test
lab and now that I've shown you how to
use this unified set of api's that
decouple the act of actually writing a
test from where it's going to run I'll
hand you over to my colleague Stefan
who's going to show you how you can run
these tests in the new simplified world
Stefan
[Applause]
Thank You Jonathan welcome everyone ten
years entered quite amazing I also want
to say a big welcome to everybody who is
joining us at the livestream today at
Google we believe that testing should be
a fundamental part of your app
development strategy let's bring back
the pyramid as we can see our friend
with the chat pack has solved the API
dilemma now that we got one API to rule
them all it's really easy to start
writing tests for Android no more
excuses we can start with a simple test
for our business logic usually a unit
test and over time we can add more and
more tests once we start implementing
the UI for our application it might be
worth adding an integration test this
chest became a fluent experience since
both layers support the same api's no
more context switching great but that's
not the only use case where the new API
became really handy let's imagine we
have an integration test I got two large
and complicated I have seen many of
those tests it's just too convenient to
test business logic and UI flow in one
single test at Google we don't like
those tests they are hard to read and
they tend to become flaky small well
focused tests are much better
so let's refactor this large complicated
test refactoring a large test can be a
very painful task
Queeny audience has experienced this
recently raise your hand
here's some good news for you if the
original test was written with the new
API this test become much simpler we
still have to test our UI and we'll keep
this part in the integration test this
layer provides high fidelity and we
don't want to lose that for our UI test
the rest mainly business logic can
directly go into the unit test layer
here we gain speed since we can run off
device on the local java vm so let's
verify the refactoring together we still
have high fidelity for the UI test
that's good we gain speed even better
and the tests are decoupled and less
complex nice job
your co-workers will thank you so let's
run those tests but wait we still have
to choose a random environment it's not
obvious trivial to pick the right one we
also have to work in multiple source
sets the combination of runtime
environments plus source sets full lead
to an explosion of test configurations
just imagine how hard it will get to
choose the right configuration should I
run on a device or offer device and
don't we need to run the entire test
suite on our continuous integration
server before we submit and you all know
the feeling I have to be kicked off the
test run waiting eagerly for the results
Oh No
how to submit one of the test is flaky
i'm pretty sure many of you have been in
this situation flakiness is one of the
biggest pain points for developer
productivity so what if there was a
better way
to set up your test harness execute your
tests in a reliable environment with
unified test results today we are proud
to announce project nitrogen the new
single entry point for all Android tests
nitrogen is fuel for your jetpacks with
our expertise of running billions of
tests a year we had to build the fastest
and most reliable test executor nitrogen
covers the entire testing lifecycle from
set up to test execution and reporting
nitrogen provides deterministic behavior
across different pool systems it will be
fully integrated in Android studio at
Google we already used nitrogen to test
our own apps such as Gmail google maps
photos YouTube and many more nitrogen is
highly extensible it provides api's for
test authors to customize the test
invocation at any point nitrogen will be
fully open sourced later this year but
let me give you an overview
starting with setup natural chain
connects your test to any execution
environment on device of device or in
the cloud it installs required test
artifacts and if necessary it can run
custom fixture scripts for you let me
show you how this works first natural
chain finds and provisions a device this
can either be a simulated device a
virtual device or real device once the
device is ready nitrogen installs the
application
under test and the test matrix n stages
any test data dependencies and sets
device properties if additional setup is
necessary it can all be done here let me
give you examples setting up a network
tunnel starting an emetic server caning
granting permissions and much more and
finally it prepares the device for the
next step test execution there are many
ways how we can run an Android test it's
a little bit like running in the real
world here we have Sprint's with
distance and long distance runs we also
have different environments direct
running Road running cross-country
running and mountain running a unit test
on your local workstation is like a
sprint as fast as possible to the finish
line the tests read on your continuous
integration server is the marathon the
goal is to get to the finish line and
not to fail along the way today these
tests are executed in different ways
from the command line from Android
studio or triggered automatically when
you submit with project nitrogen this
will become consistent we provide a
valid affiant protocol and our unifying
all the Android test offerings natural
chain uses our own device infrastructure
to run your tests Android Orchestrator
and enrich a unit runner you can already
enable the own device infrastructure
today it has been available since
Android studio 3.0
the orchestrator collects your tests and
kicks off test execution by running each
test in a separate process shared state
is minimized and crashes are isolated
moreover your tests are executed in a
familiar j-unit environment provided by
an original runner the orchestrator
collects all test results additional
artifacts and streams it back to
nitrogen-nitrogen provides a unified
reporting format for these test results
in addition it provides a huge selection
of test output data such as logcat
screenshots video profiling data battery
performance and much more all artifacts
are scoped per test this means that for
example a Lockett snippet is reduced to
the test method no more digging through
hundreds of lines of Lockett so let me
show you how nitrogen improves the
entire testing flow on Android first
nitrogen finds the device and configures
it for the test run second it runs tests
in isolation using the orchestrator and
finally while tests are running nitrogen
host-side infrastructure will be
streaming the test results from the
device pulling down all test output data
and feeding it back to you with nitrogen
all this complexity is hidden from you
whether you are running a test on
Android studio or on a CI server
nitrogen is the single entry point for
all Android tests it works from a sprint
to a marathon natural Chen can regress
the device in a fire base test lab
reliably running your tests returning
unified test results nitrogen supports
Google Cloud from your workstation you
can deploy and run tests on the real
device or on a virtual device nitrogen
works seamlessly with Rob Electric now
we can treat Rove electric as a
simulated device with raw electric 4.0
we have made big improvements in
start-up time and memory consumption raw
electric for bond oil is released today
and if this is not enough nitrogen
supports your custom needs for example
if you have an in-house device let allow
me to summarize previously you had to
learn multiple approaches for doing the
same thing tools like the mobility to
move between the layers of the pyramid
you had to choose wisely we have reduced
the cognitive load by providing you a
single set of api's that work across
environments for both on and off
scenarios and a single entry point for
Android tests with the flexibility to
customize any point in the test
invocation jetpack with nitrogen is a
child leap forward in test automation
for Android write your test once run it
everywhere
[Applause]
this is just the beginning now you have
both the tools and the knowledge to
accelerate your testing experience I
strongly encourage you to check out our
collabs especially our latest edition
building Android apps with basil basil
is the open source version of our
internal build system allowing you to
build large Android apps at Google scale
if you have further questions or if you
would like to discuss your testing
strategy come find us tomorrow morning
at 11 a.m. in the office our stand in
section 8 we hope you enjoyed our
session and we will love to hear from
you so please take a moment to submit
your feedback and with that happy
testing
[Applause]
[Music]